des centaines de parisiens entassés le
long du canal saint-martin et ce parfois
au mépris des gestes barrières le canal
saint martin un lieu aujourd'hui
attractif et touristique
pourtant c'était à l'origine un quartier
populaire et industriels depuis les
années 60 puis s'est littéralement
métamorphosé c'est quand même ces
sympathiques même quand on descend un
peu plus bas il ya un peu de verdure
c'est très bien à son inauguration en
1825 le canal saint martin c'est un
aqueduc et une voie commerciale pour le
transport de marchandises au début des
années 60
le transport fluvial et remplacer peu à
peu par la voiture ou le train
si bien que le canal a failli être
remplacée par une autoroute en 1964 le
canal saint martin vient d'être condamné
par le pari nouveau alain du nord au sud
autos et camions remplaceront les
péniches finalement le projet sera
abandonné en 1971 le canal saint-martin
reste un canal mais de moins en moins
une voie commerciale
il y a encore des péniche sur le canal
saint martin mais de moins en moins en
moyenne six par jour
on y transporte trois fois moins de
marchandises qu'il y a dix ans résultat
la vie industrielle disparaît
progressivement la population ouvrière
aussi des usines des entrepôts sont
détruits le quartier se transforme à la
fin des années 70 des travaux sont
lancés pour aménager les quais
sur les berges du canal les aménagements
viennent de commencer
les espaces verts vont petit à petit
chasser les voitures du quai de vanier
première manche gagnée par l'écologie
petit à petit le canal devient un lieu
de promenade de flânerie propice au
tourisme fluvial à la fin des années 80
les croisières touristiques se développe
entre la bastille et la villette
naviguer sur les 4,5 km du canal
c'est aussi l'occasion de découvrir la
capitale autrement également
juriste
maison de paris qui est tout à fait
différent paris insolite c'est des vieux
quartiers parisiens
au début des années 2000 de nouveaux
commerces vu le jour fini les usines et
entrepôts place aux galeries d'art et
aux boutiques de luxe clé mais aussi du
temps où il y avait encore quelques
ateliers quelques quelques
notre atmosphère atmosphère célèbre du
quartier heures aujourd'hui le canal
saint martin est l'un des endroits les
plus prisés du 10e arrondissement
si vous voulez y habiter il va falloir
mettre la main à la poche en moyenne en
le prix au mètre carré atteignez les
onze mille 700 euros
[Musique]